[Música]
me acuerdo particularmente de una noche
llena de estrellas puntitos blancos por
todos lados
en una noche fría
estábamos con mis amigos y mis
compañeros alrededor de un fogón
me acuerdo del olor del fuego
me acuerdo del calorcito del contacto
con mis compañeros
me acuerdo del orgullo y la emoción que
sentíamos por haber logrado subir juntos
aquella montaña en la patagonia
pero de lo que más me acuerdo es de las
historias que nos contábamos en ese
fogón
y una de las historias que más me
acuerdo
es una muy particular que cambió la
manera en la que yo veo al mundo
es una historia que tal vez algunos de
ustedes conozcan es aquella que cuenta
que el pueblo aimara
piensa en el paso del tiempo de una
manera totalmente distinta a la que
nosotros habitualmente pensamos
mientras usualmente nosotros pensamos el
futuro como aquello que está adelante y
el pasado atrás el pueblo aimara lo
piensa distinto piensa que aquello que
tenemos por delante es lo que conocemos
el pasado
y lo que está atrás lo que no el futuro
y en la medida en la que esta persona va
caminando hacia atrás
el pasado el futuro se revela y se
convierte en pasado
después de escuchar esta historia nunca
más pude pensar en el tiempo de la misma
manera
las historias tienen la capacidad de
acompañar a las ideas a transformar el
mundo de las personas que las escuchan
y con un equipo en argentina en buenos
aires organizamos eventos como estos el
equipo de td x río de la plata' hace
eventos como los que estamos hoy acá
donde el objetivo es justamente ese que
alguien cuenta una idea y que cambie la
manera en la que las ideas se organizan
dentro de la cabeza de los que están
escuchando
esta posibilidad de cambiar la cabeza a
la manera en la que se ordenan las ideas
o las ideas de las otras personas es
algo bastante complejo porque para hacer
una charla como las que se dan en estos
eventos es necesario pasar por un
proceso en general no sabemos los que
alguna vez nos paramos a dar charlas
cómo estás cómo hacer esas charlas
construyendo esas charlas pasan cosas
impresionantes en general pasamos mucho
tiempo acompañando a los oradores a que
desarrollen estas charlas primero que
sinteticen las ideas y después a que
construyan estas historias
lo interesante es que al final del
proceso nosotros como les dije recién
esperamos que estas ideas transformen a
los que las escuchan pero los que nos
cuentan que fueron más transformados son
los oradores porque al pasar este
proceso descubren que las ideas que
tenían estaban acompañadas de un
contexto
se les ocurren nuevas ideas tratando de
entender por qué tuvieron la anterior se
conectan con otros que tienen ideas y
entonces producen ideas juntos y un
montón de cosas más que les pasan a las
personas que dan estas charlas
entonces cuando nos dimos cuenta con el
equipo que lo que pasaba en ese proceso
era algo realmente transformador algunos
que somos educadores empezamos a pensar
que tal vez había algo impresionante que
podía pasar en las escuelas y así fue
como creamos el programa que hoy se
llama club que básicamente es un
proyecto para que un grupo de
estudiantes junto a sus docentes
atraviesan un proceso similar al que
pasan los oradores entre dx y que ese
proceso en donde parten donde les
proponemos que partan encontrando algo
que los moviliza y los apasiona y que
luego avancen sobre crear una idea a
partir de eso y por último aprender a
comunicarlo en un formato de charlas
tipo test que termina dándose en un
evento interno dentro del colegio
produce cosas impresionantes en los
chicos
en los últimos años
más o menos 500 escuelas de argentina
están haciendo clubes empezamos muy
poquitas 8 y ahora son 500 y 4.000
escuelas de todo el mundo también lo
están haciendo
lo que pasa es impresionante pero lo que
pasa en los chicos es increíble
déjenme contarles una historia de uno de
los chicos que pasó por un club de
buenos aires en su institución educativa
brandon comenzó el club
y cuando uno comienza el club lo primero
que pasa es que el facilitador se acerca
a vos y te pregunta que te moviliza que
te apasiona que te saca de la silla
y ahora no respondió no sé
claro nunca le habían hecho esa pregunta
suena raro no si yo le digo que en
realidad esa pregunta en general no se
la hacemos a los estudiantes en la
escuela
debería pasar no pero bueno la cuestión
es que no pasó y esa era la primera vez
que alguien le preguntaba eso hablando y
su respuesta era no sé entonces él se
fue con la tarea de tratar de encontrar
algo que lo moviliza que la pasión que
después lo puede acompañar durante todo
el proceso
hizo la tarea que escribió en una hoja
todas las cosas que le interesaban o que
le indignaban o que le generaban algún
tipo de emoción
y se dio cuenta que había algo que a él
le volvía loco que era el tránsito
investigando un poquito se dio cuenta
que en realidad el mundo de la movilidad
urbana era algo que le parecía súper
interesante en donde había un montón de
cosas que podía aprender y que también a
él lo apasionaba entonces volvió a la
escuela
le dijo a sus compañeros la historia
encontré lo que me apasiona la movilidad
urbana y los convenios lo miraron y lo
primero que le contaron es de qué estás
hablando qué es la movilidad urbana
carlo él tenía la expectativa que sus
compañías de dientes si a mí también y
trabajemos juntos eso no pasó a nadie ni
siquiera sabía que era
entonces su docente le dijo bueno
investiga un poco sobre el tema y
profundiza un poco más
y entonces brandon hizo algo un poco
distinto a lo que estamos acostumbrados
a ver qué pasaría que se imaginan qué
pasa con un chico que le piden que
profundice sobre algún tema yo lo
primero que pienso es que probablemente
entre un navegador y google movilidad
urbana y las primeras cosas que
encuentre haga clic entre un poquito en
el mejor de los casos lea o vea algunas
fotos o videos tal vez en youtube y no
mucho más bueno hablando un poquito más
allá
se fijó en internet quiénes eran las
personas que más sabían del tema
y decidió que probablemente una de las
personas que más sabe del tema sea el
ministro de transporte
entonces dijo ok
voy a profundizar para acá al día
siguiente de pide un compañero que
después de clase lo acompaña
le dijo a su madre y su madre que iba a
volver un poco más tarde se tomaron un
colectivo y fuera una plaza de mayo la
plaza de mayo es el lugar en buenos
aires en donde están todos los edificios
públicos
llegó a plaza de mayo se bajó del
colectivo él no había estado antes en
plaza de mayo es un lugar administrativo
por félix es una ciudad muy grande en
general la gente no vive ahí
él había estado alguna vez en alguna
excursión pero era básicamente la
primera vez que estaba por su propia
cuenta se bajó del colectivo y se
acercaron a un policía y le preguntaron
dónde está el ministerio de transporte
el policía un poco desorientado se dio
cuenta que él tampoco sabía entonces le
preguntó a otro policía que tampoco
sabía y entonces entré me dio una
reunión de consorcio que se armó ahí en
la plaza entre algunos transeúntes y la
policía terminaron señalándole un
edificio y allá fue brandon con su amigo
caminando derecho al edificio sin ningún
miedo en cargo y entró y cuando entró se
encontró con una recepción y una señora
sentada en esa mesa preguntándole hola a
que viene y brandon le dijo hola que tal
soy brandon vengo a ver al ministro de
transporte
la esencia lo miró y le dijo
perdón quién sos soy brandon estoy
haciendo un club de de de mi escuela hay
gente la señal no tenía idea y quiero
hablar con el ministro de transporte
esperando que le dijo el apellido le
dijo algún que otro dato más que le pide
el hijo no mira brandon el ministro es
una persona muy ocupada si vos querés
hablar con él tenés que pedir una
audiencia y grandes oquedades pide una
audiencia
la señora de vuelta sonrío un poco con
un poco de ternura pero también sabiendo
que esto no iba a prosperar el hijo no
mira las cosas así si vos querés ver al
ministro tenés que pedir una audiencia a
través de una carta escrita a
computadora impresa firmada con todos
estos datos que te voy a pasar al campo
la señora pensó le voy a decir esto a
brandon liberando mantener que irse y
algún día volver a tal vez sí tal vez
nunca y todo bien
blandón le dijo espera espérame un
segundito claro en las cinco y media el
ministerio cerraba a las seis
blandón acababa de salir de la escuela
quedaba media hora
brandon salió corriendo con su amigo y
se fueron a un cibercafé que que daba la
vuelta escribieron la carta rápido
seguramente se le filtraron algunos
errores de ortografía alguna palabra
manuscrita pero había una carta con
todos los datos que la señora le había
pedido y volvió corriendo al ministerio
1755 o la señora acá está mi carta desde
el ministro
la señora nuevamente con esa sonrisa que
ya les conté que la caracterizaba le
dijo bueno voy a ver qué hago mira son
faltan cinco minutos para que cerremos
hoy no va a poder ser le dijo déjame ver
qué puedo hacer pero hoy no va a poder
ser así que anda tu casa que tu mamá te
debe estar esperando
y si sabemos algo te contactamos esto es
como cuando vas a un casting y alguien
te dice bueno te vamos a llamar uno sabe
que eso probablemente no suceda entonces
brandon se fue un poco decepcionado él
había hecho todo lo que podía pero no
había conseguir el objetivo esto no era
como entrar a un jueguito y resolver un
problema y pasar del siguiente nivel se
había encontrado con una traba entonces
se fue la casa y pasaron un par de días
pasaron 34 pasaron una semana una semana
y media y recibió el llamado
lo estaban llamando del ministerio de
transporte porque el ministro quería
hablar con él
claro blandón pensó el ministro es la
persona que más sabe de transporte
probablemente sabe bastante de móvil y
urbana brandon de política no sabe nada
entonces no se dio cuenta tal vez que el
ministro deporte no era necesariamente
la persona que más sabía pero fue
encontrarse con él y charlando se dio
cuenta de esto y también se dio cuenta
que no tenía mejores respuestas para las
preguntas que él tenía pero sí tenía
mejores preguntas
cuando yo escuché lo que hizo brandon
en su charla me di cuenta que su charla
ya no era sobre movilidad urbana la
historia que me estaba contando no tenía
nada que ver sobre movilidad urbana a
pesar de que eso era el tema que a él lo
movilizó para pasar por esta experiencia
brandon me implantó una idea a mí sobre
cómo acercarme al conocimiento
él se preguntó cómo puedo saber más de
esto y su respuesta fue simple pero algo
que a mí no se me había ocurrido voy a
hablar con la persona que más sabe de
este tema
y voy a encontrarla y voy a dirigirme
directamente para tratar de aprender de
esa persona
claro hoy esas personas están a
distancia de un tuit de un mail
de tocarle la puerta un ministro
o de algún llamado telefónico o de algún
amigo que conoce a alguien que conoce a
alguien es bastante simple si lo piensa
en un segundo es bastante simple
lo que él contó nos impactó tanto como
equipo a nosotros que hasta incluso
creamos una actividad nueva que
incluimos en el proceso de club este de
que antes no estaba que internamente la
llamamos la actividad la actividad
brandon es parte del proceso y lo que
les proponemos a los chicos que hagan es
que a partir de el tema que eligieron
hagan un mapa de las personas que más
saben sobre ese tema en su comunidad o
sea en su escuela en su familia en su
barrio después un nuevo círculo en su
ciudad en su pueblo
y después en el mundo
y que a partir de eso salgan a buscar
esas personas
hace poquito un amigo que es una persona
muy inteligente y es muy especialista en
un tema muy particular
me dijo que me llamó alguien me llamó un
chico que está haciendo un club de d
no me acuerdo ahora qué provincia de
argentina que quería hablar conmigo
porque estaba haciendo una actividad de
mapear quiénes estaban quienes sabían de
este tema o sea que está sucediendo
las ideas
son increíbles y las historias tienen la
capacidad de acompañar esas ideas de
maneras que ni siquiera nos podemos nos
podemos imaginar cuando las formulamos
porque no terminan cuando las contamos a
partir de ahí tienen vida propia dentro
de la cabeza de cada uno de los que la
escuchan
y por eso yo me sigo acordando de esos
campamentos y de ese cielo estrellado y
del olorcito a fuego de las historias
que nos contábamos
y de las muchas historias que estuve
escuchando de miles de chicos de todo mi
país
y me dio cuenta que esas historias y
esas ideas están cambiando el mundo
bueno no sé si el mundo al menos mi
mundo
una idea a la vez
[Aplausos]